تخيلوا ان هذا القلم كاد يتسبب في رسوبها
واقعه غريبه حدثت مع طالبه سوريه عندما
تفاجات بحصولها على علامات صفر في احدى
المواد رغم اجابتها عن الاسئله بشكل صحيح
الطالبه اعتراضات لدى اداره الجامعه التي
اكتشفت ان ورقتها بيضاء تحتوي فقط على
الاسئله دون اجابات ما اصابت طالبه
بالذهول الجامعه استعانت بكاميرات
المراقبه التي اثبتت ان الطالبه كانت تجيب
فعلا ووسط استغراب الجميع انحسرت الشكوك
حول القلم الذي يبدو للوهله الاولى عاديا
لكن توجد عليهم ملاحظه بالانجليزيه بان
حبره يختفي بعد الكتابه ولن يعود الا بوضع
الورقه في الثلاجه وبحراره سالب عشره وضعت
الورقه اخيرا في براد الجامعه لتظهر
اجابات طالبه ويتم اعاده تصحيح ورقتها من
جديد